and do you remember the first time we
ever ejaculated was it surprising to you
yeah it was mind-blowing I lost my [ __ ]
I had like a family computer room where
like it was like this room off to the
side right next to my parents room so I
had to like you know I think the first
porn ever watched
it was like the girl from Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and she was just like
stripping in the rain I don't even know
if there was even breasts involved so it
was an actual pornography it was just
like video of someone but it was like
getting close to it you know I think I
think I Googled like cool boobs I think
that was my first or hot boobs that was
my first ever
porn search and then I found it I was
like because I heard people at lunch
talking about jerking off and I was like
and you didn't and now did you know what
it was I do I had no idea this is like
uh man sixth grade the good thing about
when you hear that jerking off you only
you can kind of figure out even if
you're like you know even if you can't
even read or anything you can kind of
figure out what you have to do to kind
of achieve it it's yeah you know you can
only test everything so much before you
[ __ ] yeah so I tested that [ __ ] out man
I was I remember I think I think
everyone's first note might be their
best best nut oh it's just insane well I
just feel like the I remember the
ejaculate
or the e-jack or whatever they call it
you know
um yeah it's so at that point it's so
clear yep I remember being like it had
just
I mean like it had just come out of like
it was just pure man it was like plasma
it's like a pure oh child
nut you know what I'm saying no
yeah man that was uh let's all say it
again I know what you're saying because
I was a child and you were a child so we
can say it but I think yeah it's weird I
don't want to think about it but I think
about it but yeah we were talking about
ourselves as yeah yeah it was our own
pure child's nuts so yeah dude if I'm
thinking about my own self ejacqueline
as a kid that's not like pedophile stuff
is it no no it's your own nut man I'll
never forget my first like five nights
how old were you when you first boss
everyone yeah thanks man how old were
you
um I was uh oh I think I remember I was
like 13. and I didn't really know I
remember like
uh finding some videos right my brother
had some pornography up there hidden in
his closet and some Alize whiskey pull
up some Alize
hey bro I'll still sip some smells
everywhere oh dude yeah if I want my
camera so you got into the whiskey it's
not like a weird little like it's a mix
it's like a little bit oh there it is
right now right there get that orange
one baby or the oh yeah that one that's
what I remember yeah oh god dude oh that
was that shit's popping especially like
oh I can Belch and taste my childhood
even just looking at it and so he had a
he had a jug of that up there and I
found some videos on his shelf and so I
hit two swigs of that
and I fell off the shelf man I got drunk
it was like I climbed up some shells in
his closet and fell off that [ __ ] and
then jerked off and then I I kind of
came too I think I even blacked out and
damn that's a crazy first night there
was a lot going on and then I got these
videos and I put it in the video player
and I just remember like laying in his
in my brother's bed because his bed was
by the TV and he was out of town and
like I like your brother's bed was your
first first night I didn't think about
that
crazy damn bro all right you know things
happen
God bro but he wasn't there yeah no I
respected up a little bit
oh yeah dude I think yeah I mean I think
it just evaporated back into my skin it
was like you know that [ __ ] was pure
that was damn place that's gonna reform
of thumb you know she could really bro
if you were missing something you could
fit them in a divot on your body but I
do remember like having my legs out and
I remember just kind of rubbing my I was
so like irre like just volatile from
watching the pornography that I remember
even just rubbing my legs together like
this and that alone was just too much
going oh it was just too much Charisma
going on just heat yeah oh I even just
my own legs because I'd never like if
you took 30 seconds before if I'd rub my
legs that had been nothing but now that
I'm all Keen in on this pornography and
titty on the video
um it just had taken a new level and I
just
dude oh I had no prior knowledge of what
was about to go down so I'm in that
[ __ ] like just you know getting to it
however I could I think I might have had
like a silky napkin or something oh God
yeah of course you would
you're gonna I mean I was probably gonna
have a capo on Brandon no no no no bro I
was like third I was not balling when I
was [ __ ] 14 man I uh
yeah I don't know some napkin and and I
just remember like it was like damn this
is cool man I'm really getting into this
and then I busted and I was like you
know it's like a it's like take it's
like blasting off on DMT I was like it
really is damn I was like that's what
happens and then my dick look [ __ ] up
for like two days oh wow really Jesus it
just had been so swollen you know what
I'm saying yeah
yeah it is it's almost like popping a
pimple for the first time yeah God I
remember I remember I saw a man
um cream out on a video
and I was like there's no way it must be
a special effect or something yeah and
so I remember you know doing myself like
that just genie in my little lamp dude
and God damn brother I mean just
somebody somebody wished for damn semen
I would I would pay money to have my
first jerk off again man I swear to God
goodness gracious
and pay money for what and like just
just have it just to have never nutted
in my life oh to scratch all the nuts I
ever took and just have my first again
right now
dude I think you have to uh there's
that's like born again Christian or not
I don't know if that they do it there
but baptized and have a good another
first jerk off but you can't really do
all the reverse God yeah I think it's
over man the track has been worn and
he's I've damaged the goods
but there is something about it man if
you go all the way back it almost feels
like you'd never die if you had never
jerked off
wow
it was deep
I think I agree with that
you don't have to agree with that
statement man [ __ ] it's like you'd have
this power inside of you God
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one